E
IRANIAN MULLAHS FOR THIS ACTION?
BUT FIRST, LET'S TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE DECREPIT,
STRUGGLING, BARELY-FUNCTIONING
GUY IN THE WHITE HOUSE WHO SEES
APPARENTLY JIM CROW AROUND EVERY
TURN.
IT REMEMBERED JOE BIDEN HE ONCE
CALLED AFRICAN-AMERICANS
PREDATORS ON OUR STREETS.
HE WORRIED THAT HIS PRECIOUS
CHILDREN WOULD GROW UP IN
INTEGRATED SCHOOLS THAT HE
REFERRED TO AS "RACIAL JUNGLES,
HIS WORDS.
HE BRAGGED THAT HIS HOME STATE
OF DELAWARE "MY STATE AS A STATE
HE SAID.
HE WORKED HAND-IN-HAND WITH
AMERICA'S MOST NOTORIOUS RACIST
TO BLOCK THE INTEGRATION OF OUR
SCHOOLS AND BUSSING.
ROBERT BYRD, THE FORMER CLAN
LEADER WAS BIDEN'S MENTOR IN THE
SENATE, CORDING TO JOE, AND THE
REST OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
NONE OF THAT MATTERS.
NOW ACCORDING TO JOE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS ARE WORSE THAN
JIM CROW, ALL BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORT SIMPLE ELECTION
INTEGRITY MEASURES.
WATCH FOR YOURSELF.
>> President Biden:
21ST CENTURY JIM CROW ASSAULT IS
REAL.
IT'S UNRELENTING.
THERE'S AN UNFOLDING ASSAULT
TAKING PLACE IN AMERICA TODAY,
AND ATTEMPT TO SUPPRESS AND
SUBVERT THE RIGHT TO VOTE IN
FAIR AND FREE ELECTIONS.
THE ASSAULT ON FREE AND FAIR
ELECTIONS IS JUST SUCH A THREAT,
LITERALLY.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE.
WE ARE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
THAT'S NOT HYPERBOLE.
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Sean: SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
JOE PROBABLY REMEMBERS THE GOOD
OLD DAYS I GUESS IN HIS LIFE.
HE SERVED, WHAT, DELAWARE HOW
MANY YEARS AT THIS POINT?
LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN FOR YOU
BURIED ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN
AMERICA IS FACING ITS WORST
CRISIS SINCE THE CIVIL WAR
BECAUSE OF THE TEXAS ELECTION
BILL.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN TONIGHT.
THIS BILL BANS PAID BALLOT
HARVESTING.
TO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT?
IT REQUIRES VOTER I.D. FOR
MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
ALTERNATIVELY, VOTERS CAN
PROVIDE THE LAST FOUR DIGITS OF
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER IF
THEY PREFER.
THE BILL SETS UNIFORM TIMES FOR
EARLY VOTING, ALL WHILE
EXPANDING EARLY VOTING HOURS ON
THE WEEKEND.
IT ENSURES THAT POLL WATCHERS
ARE ABLE, ACCORDING TO LAW,
OBSERVE VOTE COUNTING.
START TO FINISH, ALL GOT SIDES
GET TO OBSERVE.
IT STRENGTHENS THE BAN ON
DROP BOX IS SOMETHING THE
VARIOUS CAN HAPPEN, KEEP PEOPLE
HONEST BURIED IT GIVES VOTERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT MISTAKES
ON MAIL-IN BALLOTS IF THEY ARE
DISCOVERED.
THE BILL REQUIRES THOSE
ASSISTING BOATERS WITH FILLING
OUT THERE BALLOTS TO COMPLETE A
FORM VERIFYING THEIR IDENTITY
AND IT ENDS THE TEMPORARY
EMERGENCY MEASURES THAT WERE PUT
IN PLACE BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC, LIKE DRIVE-THROUGH
VOTING AND 24-HOUR EARLY VOTING.
JOE BIDEN QUITE LITERALLY IS
CALLING THIS BILL THE MOST
RACIST THING TO HAPPEN IN THE
UNITED STATES THIS CENTURY.
ALL RIGHT, PRETTY INSANE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THIS SIMPLE FACT.
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL, IT IS NOW
EASIER TO VOTE IN TEXAS THAN IN
JOE BIDEN'S HOME STATE OF
DELAWARE.
THAT'S WHY HE IS NOW WEAPONIZING
HIS OWN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
GO AFTER ATLANTA.
THEY HAVE FAR MORE ACCESSIBILITY
TO VOTING THEN DELAWARE AND IN
THE STATE OF TEXAS, THERE ARE
TWO WEEKS OF EARLY VOTING.
IN DELAWARE, THERE ARE ZERO
WEEKS OF EARLY VOTING.
IN TEXAS THERE ARE DROP
LOCATIONS FOR ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
IN DELAWARE, WELL, DROP BOXES --
WELL, THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED.
BOTH STATES REQUIRE VOTER I.D.,
BUT IN HIS, WHAT, 5,000 PLUS
YEARS REPRESENT IN THE GREAT
STATE OF DELAWARE, JOE NOT ONE
TIME EVER VOICED ANY CONCERN
WHATSOEVER ABOUT HIS OWN STATE'S
RESTRICTIVE ELECTION LAWS.
NEVER, NOT ONCE.
INSTEAD HE WAS TOO BUSY SAYING
THINGS LIKE -- WELL, THIS.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
PREDATORS ON OUR STREETS.
>> THE LARGEST GROWTH IN
POPULATION IS INDIAN AMERICANS.
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-ELEVEN OR A
DUNKIN' DONUTS IN LESS YOU HAVE
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT KIND OF A CHANCE WITH A
NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL LIKE
JOE BIDEN STAND IN THE SOUTH?
>> BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU DON'T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A SLAVE STATE.
>> SORT OF MAINSTREAM CHRISTIAN
AMERICA.
ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND A
NICE-LOOKING GUY.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO PUT YOU ALL
BACK IN CHAINS.
>> WE GOT MORE QUESTIONS.
>> GIVE MORE QUESTIONS -- IF YOU
HAVE A PROBLEM, FIGURE OUT
WHETHER YOU ARE FOR ME OR TRUMP,
THEN YOU AIN'T BLACK.
>> Sean: THE GUY WHO TRIED TO
SLOW INTEGRATION OF OUR SCHOOLS,
EULOGIZE THE FORMER CLAN LEADER.
CALLED OBAMA THE FIRST
ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT AND CLEAN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THIS IS STORYBOOK, MAN.
THOSE ARE JOE'S WORDS.
NOW THAT GUY, JOE BIDEN, HE'S
GOING TO LECTURE THE COUNTRY
ABOUT RACISM?
REALLY?
ALLOW ME TO STATE A FACT THAT
MIGHT SURPRISE JOE BIDEN.
AMERICANS, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
RACE OR GENDER, THEY ARE CAPABLE
INTELLIGENT HUMAN BEINGS.
I HAVE FAITH IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE DON'T ALWAYS WIN THE
ELECTIONS WE WANT TO WIN, BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE COME BACK.
CONSERVATISM ALWAYS MAKES ITS
WAY BACK, BECAUSE IT WORKS.
WAY BEFORE COVID, BEFORE ALL OF
THE MASS MAIL-IN BALLOTS IN THE
24-HOUR DRIVE-THROUGH VOTING
CENTERS AND THE WEEKS AND WEEKS
OF EARLY VOTING,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN TURNOUT WAS
ACTUALLY REACHING RECORD LEVELS.
NOW, IN FACT, IT WAS A STUDY,
ACCORDING TO THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS EVEN PRINTED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THAT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS TURNED
OUT AT A HIGHER RATE THAN WHITE
VOTERS IN 2012 AND 28.
IT TEXAS DEMOCRATS DON'T APPEAR
INTERESTED IN FACTS.
GRANDSTANDING IS FAR TOO
IMPORTANT TO THEM AND SO
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS, THEY FLED
THEIR STATE IN ORDER TO PREVENT
A QUORUM AND THEREBY TEMPORARILY
BLOCKING A VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THEY BOARDED
THEIR PRIVATE JET, NO MASKS
INSIDE, JUST A SIDEBAR, AND ARE
NOW ENJOYING A LAVISH VACATION
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., COMPLETE
WITH SPEECHES AND SELFIES AND
PARTYING AND TWEETS ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE EATING.
KAMALA HARRIS CALLED THE TRIP
COURAGEOUS, IN-LINE WITH THE
BRAVE ACTIONS OF
FREDERICK DOUGLASS.
WATCH.
>> I HAD AN EXTENSIVE MEETING
YESTERDAY WITH I THINK SOME OF
THE MOST COURAGEOUS ELECTED
LEADERS THAT WE COULD KNOW AT
THIS MOMENT.
I SAID IT YESTERDAY AND I'LL SAY
IT AGAIN.
THEY TOOK BOLD, COURAGEOUS
ACTION IN LINE WITH THE LEGACY
OF EVERYONE FROM
FREDERICK DOUGLASS, WHO IS OVER
MY RIGHT SHOULDER, WHEN HE
FOUGHT FOR THE RIGHT OF BLACK
MEN TO VOTE IN AMERICA, TO THE
LEGACY THAT INCLUDES ALL THOSE
WOMEN WHO MARCHED DOWN
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO VOTE.
TO ALL OF THOSE FOLKS WHO SHED
THEIR BLOOD ON THE EDMUND PETTUS
BRIDGE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WOULD, IN 1965, PASS THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
>> Sean: NOW
MITCH McCONNELL, REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES, SKIPPED TOWN TO
PREVENT A QUORUM IN THE U.S.
SENATE.
LET'S SEE HOW KAMALA HARRIS
REACTS THEN.
WHAT THEY CALL THEM COURAGEOUS?
WHICH HE BE CALLING REPUBLICANS
COURAGEOUS?
I TEND TO DOUBT IT.
WHAT IS THIS REALLY ALL ABOUT?
WE ALL KNOW THERE IS NOTHING
RACIST ABOUT INTEGRITY IN THE
ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL EASILY
WORRIED.
CHANCES ARE THEY ARE NOW BELIEVE
THAT PROBABLY WILL LOSE IN 2022
AND MAYBE EVEN 2024.
THEIR GREEN NEW DEAL SOCIALIST
POLICIES ARE DEEPLY UNPOPULAR,
THEY ARE DEFUNDING THE POLICE,
DISMANTLING POLICE, SIMILARLY
DEEPLY UNPOPULAR.
THE GUY THEY PUT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IS BECOMING LESS AND
LESS COHERENT SEEMINGLY BY THE
HOUR.
SO NOW THEY ARE FRANTICALLY
SEARCHING FOR WAYS TO EXPAND
VOTING BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY,
ALL WHILE SETTING UP AN EXCUSE
FOR AN IMPENDING LOSS.
MARK MY WORDS, IF DEMOCRATS
SUFFER HUGE LOSSES IN 2022, THEY
WILL BLAME RACIST RIGHT WING
VOTERS, VOTER SUPPRESSION.
MARK THESE WORDS DOWN.
PER USUAL, IT'S ALL A LIE BUT